bonjour à tous
alors aujourd'hui comme vous pouvez le
voir on va parler d'intelligence
artificielle et de perception du monde
quoi que non attendez non non pas du
tout non finalement ouais plutôt ça
je voulais vous parler de
caractéristiques communes rencontrées
chez des personnes inspirantes
quoi que non non plus beaucoup trop fait
celui-là
bon
je suis désolé pour être honnête je sais
pas vraiment de quoi je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui enfin disons que j'ai pas
vraiment choisi pour le moment
peut-être que je me disais ce serait
possible de reporter l'événement non
passer l'année prochaine ok non plus
bon je sais pas ça vous arrive jamais
vous
de passer des heures à prendre une
décision difficile ou d'être bloqué
devant un choix
attendez regardez quand même ce nombre
un milliard
non mais un milliard quand même
c'est une estimation du nombre de choix
que vous prenez dans toute votre vie
un avec 9 0 c'est pas mal quand même
ok je vous l'accorde à raison de 35000
décisions chaque jour la plupart de vos
choix relèvent en réalité de
l'inconscient
97% pour être précis par exemple tourner
à gauche traverser la rue décider
comment vous allez vous habiller ce
matin
mais
qu'en est-il des quelque choix les plus
décisifs
vous savez c'est quelques décisions qui
peuvent vraiment impacter votre vie
chaque jour
tout à coup c'est quand même plus
complexe
et justement il y a 2 ans je décidais
d'aménager ma scolarité pouvoir
développer mon activité comme freelance
et m'engager dans la société
mais face au nombre de possibilités je
n'ai pas su dire non à certains projets
et avec l'accumulation du nombre
d'heures de travail et de responsabilité
au quotidien j'ai été propulsé par un
burn out
et depuis ce jour
je connais de sérieuses difficultés à
prendre des décisions importantes dans
ma vie et encore plus à entamer une
action devant un nombre de possibilités
trop important
et c'est exactement ce qui m'est arrivé
pour ce talk
un mois et demi un mois et demi pour
choisir un sujet au point de ne même pas
pouvoir participer
alors voilà aujourd'hui c'est vous vous
tous qui allez m'aider à choisir le
sujet
mais avant tout ce phénomène il a un nom
c'est ce qu'on appelle le paradoxe du
choix
alors l'énoncé est assez simple
assure abondance de possibilités dans
nos vies droit malheureux
un peu contre intuitif ça vous trouvez
pas pourtant d'habitude
c'est plutôt l'absence de choix qui nous
rend malheureux non par exemple je vous
dis je n'ai pas le choix
négatif quand même
alors souvent on associe cette absence
de choix une absence de liberté d'agir
sur notre vie sur notre destin et donc
un malheur inévitable
donc si on part de ce principe on peut
dire que a priori plus de choix
impliquent plus de liberté
de liberté je pense implique plus de
bonheur donc tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que plus de choix implique
plus de bonheur non
mais c'est exactement là où réside le
paradoxe
en réalité c'est bien la surabondance
des choix qui rend qui est la véritable
prison
elle réduit notre bonheur et limite nos
actions alors pour vous illustrer cela
un exemple frappant et celui des
relations amoureuses dans notre société
je vous explique
8000 c'est le nombre d'applications de
rencontre partout dans le monde
X2 c'est l'évolution du nombre de
célibataires c'est 30 dernières années
partout dans le monde aussi
bizarre non un côté il n'a jamais été
aussi simple de trouver l'amour ou au
moins de rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes et de l'autre on n'a jamais eu
autant de célibataires que c'est 20 30
dernières années
moi ça m'intrigue quand même alors
comment expliquer ce phénomène car une
explication un peu caricaturale mais je
vous l'accorde mais au moins tout le
monde comprend à peu près il y a avant a
priori la recherche de son partenaire de
vie était finalement assez simple
c'est-à-dire que souvent rencontrer
quelqu'un dans notre entourage proche
l'amour c'est un peu son boulot et on
finissait par s'engager ou non à vie
avec une personne bon assez simple
mais à l'ère du digital les choses ont
quand même pas mal changé chaque jour on
peut rencontrer plusieurs dizaines de
personnes
mais un problème subsiste
tu sais je suis pas difficile mais
cherche quand même au moins quelqu'un
qui soit sportif puis diplômé et
intelligent quoi puis drôle c'est
important ça aussi puis ambitieux mais
pas trop non plus qui va avec des
enfants mais pas trop non plus vraiment
je vous la fais courte face autant de
possibilités la liste des critères
s'allonge et en attendant que souvent
plus longtemps avant de s'engager avec
quelqu'un faute de trouver la personne
idéale on va dire le prince charmant ou
la princesse charmante parfaite
alors une des explications de ce
phénomène réside dans ce qu'on appelle
la paralysie face au choix mettez vous
en situation vous arrivez dans votre
magasin de sportware favoris et vous
tombez sur votre paire de chaussures
préférées et en plus un prix exclusif
globalement vous êtes obligé d'en
profiter
mais impossible de choisir face à tous
les coloris proposés en vitrine
et avec l'impatience de vos amis et
après quelques minutes de réflexion vous
finissez par partir finalement sans rien
acheter
c'est exactement ce qui m'arrivait pour
choisir le sujet de ce top
regardons un peu plus ce qui s'est passé
dans votre tête
voilà je me retrouve il y a de moi et je
décide de prendre le temps de choisir le
bon sujet pour mettre toutes les chances
de mon côté et faire une bonne
prestation donc là en haut on peut voir
l'évolution du nombre de sujets je
prends une feuille tout simplement je
note tous les idées qui ne passent par
la tête donc on va voir l'évolution de
ce nombre avec le temps et en bas
l'évolution de la probabilité de
commencer à entamer une action donc
c'est à dire comment ça écrire le Talk
avec le temps
voilà je me retrouve il y a deux mois je
suis très excité à l'idée de participer
donc je commence à noter des sujets
voilà une idée qui me vient en tête puis
deux trois bon je rajoute 4 5
je me retrouve il y a un mois
pas convaincu il y a aucun des sujets
qui me parlent plus que les autres il me
reste du temps je me dis je vais
continuer à chercher des sujets
donc voilà je continue et je me retrouve
littéralement il y a deux semaines avec
une liste de plein de sujets mais
impossible de choisir impossible
et je me retrouve donc à quelques jours
je n'ai pas écrit une seule ligne et je
suis prêt sur le point de retirer ma
candidature faute de préparation
et bien c'est ça la paralysie face au
choix c'est à dire plus le temps passe
et plus la probabilité d'entamer une
action face à un nombre de possibilités
trop important va devenir faible
alors comment expliquer ce phénomène
finalement alors que nous avons jamais
été aussi libre dans nos vies
et bien
à l'origine il est important de se
rappeler que la décision est un
mécanisme primitif c'est-à-dire que d'un
point de vue anthropologique il est
étroitement lié à des décisions de
l'ordre du danger du risque de la survie
et donc un stress important
votre cerveau mon cerveau n'est donc pas
fait pour faire face à autant de
stimulations décisionnelles que nous en
rencontrant chaque jour
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vous
prenez une décision et bien tout se
passe exactement ici dans le cortex
préfrontal de votre cerveau selon un
mécanisme finalement assez simple
regardez bien
tout d'abord votre cerveau va commencer
par analyser la décision à prendre et on
va dire qui va lister toutes les
punitions et les récompenses associées à
une décision similaire passée
ensuite il va faire de même c'est-à-dire
qu'il va anticiper toutes les
récompenses et toutes les punitions
associées à chacune des actions
impliquées dans le choix à venir
et dans un dernier temps
et bien il va anticiper les efforts et
les coûts associés à chacune de ces
actions et en synthétisant ces trois
informations l'élaborent un classement
de toutes ces actions dont celle de ne
rien faire
alors il y a deux mécanismes décisifs
dans ce dans ce processus de décision le
premier c'est la peur
et le second la récompense
ainsi si la peur est trop importante par
exemple la peur de l'échec la peur de la
douleur la peur à dire du regard des
autres ou si la récompense n'en vaut pas
la chandelle par exemple que sa
probabilité est trop faible ou que sa
temporalité est trop éloignée et bien
dans ces deux cas votre cerveau tendra
vers la solution la plus confortable
et à ce sujet là j'allais presque oublié
il y a un autre problème
votre cerveau déteste l'incertitude
c'est-à-dire qu'à choisir il tendra
plutôt vers une situation confortable
plutôt que de rester dans une situation
délicate
ainsi dans la plupart des situations
la solution la plus confortable la
solution la plus reposante sera celle de
facilité c'est à dire ne rien faire
c'est à dire l'inaction plutôt que la
décision
alors pourquoi cette inaction nous
rend-elle si malheureux finalement elle
devrait être assez agréable comme
absence d'effort et bien on peut
notamment l'expliquer par la conscience
des possibles c'est à dire l'écart entre
votre situation actuelle et toutes les
situations dans lesquelles vous pourriez
vous trouver avec des choix différents
et à cela difficile d'être heureux
surtout dans une société où on a
l'impression que tout le monde peut
devenir footballeur professionnel la
future star des réseaux sociaux ou le
nouvel entrepreneur en vogue votre
cerveau adore les histoires et il sera
inventé tous les scénarios possibles
pour vous faire culpabiliser de votre
situation actuelle
par exemple vous allez acheter à manger
on connaît tous cette situation vous
vous rendez au restaurant que votre ami
vous a conseillé vous êtes très content
à l'idée de tester un des plats donc
voilà vous émettez des en tout cas des
attentes par rapport à votre choix vous
dites tout ça a l'air vraiment sympa et
au moment de la décision vous regardez
une nouvelle fois la carte et vous dites
ça avait l'air pas mal ça aussi c'est ce
qu'on appelle le coût d'opportunité
c'est à dire la perte de toutes les
alternatives face au choix d'une
possibilité
finalement vous vous décidez à commander
et vous croisez quelqu'un avec un des
plats sur lesquels vous hésitiez vous
vous dites
peut-être dû prendre ça finalement
commencer déjà à anticiper le regret
et enfin
dites bon de toute façon je prends
jamais la bonne chose
je ne sais pas vous blâmer pour votre
erreur
alors effet de comparaison sur les
réseaux sociaux manque de confiance dire
qu'il y a plein d'explications tout est
bon pour susciter de la frustration en
prenant conscience de toutes les
situations dans lesquelles vous pourriez
être tout ce que vous pourriez être
faire ou avoir avec des choix différents
bon pour l'histoire tout ça mais
toujours pas à trouver un sujet
alors comment surmonter cette paralysie
comment faire ce choix et bien il y en a
qui l'ont très très bien compris ce sont
les marques
réduire le nombre de choix et la
solution numéro 1 pour surmonter
l'inaction lors d'une décision d'achat
en d'autres termes la psychologie du
choix est formelle réduire le nombre de
possibilités des clients génèrent plus
de vente
alors il y a une étude très célèbre je
vous l'accorde pas tant que ça qui
s'appelle l'étude de la confiture et qui
démontre ça très bien c'est très simple
vous prenez deux épiceries dans la
première vous mettez un étalage avec 24
pots de confiture avec des gouttes tous
différents dans la seconde seulement 6
options mais les résultats sont formels
dans la première épicerie les 24 options
ont attiré l'attention de plus de 60%
des personnes mais seulement 3% ont
acheté un pot alors que dans la seconde
seulement 40% des gens se sont arrêtés
devant les talages mais 30% ont acheté
de la confiture
bon je vous l'accorde pas toujours
évident de réduire le nombre de
possibilités ou de choix au quotidien
même si on a un qui le fait plutôt bien
c'est mon collègue Marc alors il a
décidé tout simplement de d'avoir une
garde-robe essentiellement composée de
t-shirts gris on va dire pour éviter de
perdre du temps et l'énergie chaque
matin à s'habiller
chacun son truc en tout cas le mec a pas
trop réussi en plus
alors il y a un deuxième apprentissage
que l'on peut tirer notamment de l'UEF
design vous savez c'est cette science
qui vise à appliquer la psychologie à la
conception de produits
cette méthode consisterait tout
simplement à engager les clients dans
l'action avant même le processus de
décision en d'autres termes les poussées
dans l'action avant le choix
alors il y a une start-up américaine qui
le fait très bien c'est taille forme
start-up qui est valorisé à plus de 950
millions de dollars maintenant presque
un milliard peut-être vous vous demandez
qu'est-ce qu'a fait cette start-up
finalement pour être valorisé aussi cher
ben des questionnaires en ligne en fait
tout simplement bon pas n'importe quelle
questionnaire en ligne les
questionnaires avec un taux de réponse
record leur constat est très simple
la plupart des gens se découragent se
décourage devant la taille des
questionnaires à rallonge leur solution
simple également découper ces
questionnaires en petits processus de
décision intermédiaire deux avantages à
ça le premier ça permet d'engager les
personnes dans l'action sans qu'il voit
tous les choix qui vont avoir à faire
par la suite et la deuxième réduire la
probabilité d'abandonner aussi au vu de
tous les efforts déjà fournis aux
questions précédentes
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut tirer
concrètement de tout ça dans nos vies
pour faire des choix mais en réalité
trois choses la première c'est
l'importance de se mettre en mouvement
face à l'appareilisme en d'autres termes
prendre une décision bonne ou mauvaise
mais se mettre dans une dynamique
positive et notamment ce que propose la
règle des 5 secondes qui suggère en tout
cas qu'il ne faudrait pas attendre plus
de 5 secondes avant d'entamer une action
délicate pour ainsi passer de
spectateurs à acteurs de ses choix et
surmonter la paralysie
le deuxième apprentissage utilisez
l'effet cumulé pourquoi affronter des
choix colossaux quand on peut faire de
petites décisions les efforts perçus par
votre cerveau en seront donc réduits il
sera plus simple de faire de petits
choix individuels
et la dernière
possibilité c'est d'accepter l'erreur
c'est un des mantras de la philosophie
du chaos
l'univers et chaos et en tant que partie
de l'univers notre vie étant partie
chaos il faut donc apprendre à vivre
dans ce chaos de ne pas tout maîtriser
accepter l'erreur et surtout adapter une
démarche
itérative face aux erreurs
alors si je peux terminer avec un
apprentissage un dernier apprentissage
que la vie m'a donné à ce sujet là en
réalité souvent les meilleures décisions
sont celles qui viennent du coeur je me
rends compte que je passe beaucoup de
temps à essayer de faire ce que je peux
plutôt que ce que je veux vraiment et
comme le disait si bien Amélie Nothomb
le seul mauvais choix et l'absence de
choix vous connaissez l'adage mieux va
voir des remords plutôt que des regrets
et en attendant j'espère que vous ferez
tous les bons choix merci à tous
[Applaudissements]